ja wir haben gerade schon gehört
deutschland ist das land der fleißigen
der tüchtigen der leistungsträger aber
wir haben auch gehört dass die politik
gehen nicht immer wieder spricht und ich
möchte die these sogar noch weiter
fassen ich glaube dass unser staat viel
zu häufig leistung harter arbeit und
fleiß bestraft da könnte ich jetzt sieg
bei spielen angefangen bei der kalten
progression wo man dann in die nächst
steuerklasse reinfeld und dann ganz
wenig von seiner lohnerhöhung hat bis
zum spitzensteuersatz der sich bis in
die mitte der gesellschaft vor gefressen
hat 1965 musste man das 15-fache des
durchschnitts einkommen verdienen jetzt
ist nur dass 1,5 möchte aber ein anderes
beispiel nehmen was symbolisch für eine
gewisse leistungsfeindlich kite steht
und das ist dass kinder und jugendliche
die in familien groß werden die
arbeitslosengeld 2 beziehen hartz iv wie
es dann so nennt wenn die nebenjob haben
450 euro arbeiten regale einräumen an
der tankstelle job und ich habe in der
bäckerei gejobbt und 5 uhr morgens auf
den sonntag um brötchen verkauft nach
der partie die dürfe von ihren 450 euro
nebenjob nur 170 euro behalten ab einem
freibetrag von 100 euro werden 80
prozent eingerechnet das setzt sich in
den köpfen fest und gerade bei
denjenigen müssten wir sagen wir
belohnen dich dafür dass du dich
anstrengen ist raus arbeitet hier in
führerschein kaufen willst was für die
erste eigene wohnung zu ersparen wird
und eigentlich glaube ich steht das so
symbolisch für so eine gewisse um
leistungs ungerechtigkeit und ich finde
wir sollten in deutschland in den
wahlkämpfen weniger um umverteilung
drehen und mehr darüber wie kann ich
durch harte arbeiten den vermögen
aufbauen wie wertig belohnt auch wenn
ich tüchtig und leistet bin war das ist
das was haben wir gerade gehört was uns
in deutschland eigentlich auszeichnet
klassische gedanke der
leistungsgesellschaft leistung muss sich
wieder lohnen also bin ich absolut dafür
auch wenn es ein bisschen sache ist aus
den 80ern des letzten jahrhunderts da
weil es ja die die formel von ronald
reagan margaret thatcher
juni weiter gefüllt von helmut kohl aber
dann doch eher von gerhard schröder und
dann
natürlich bill clinton tony blair die
diese marktwirtschaftliche aspekte und
diesen leistungsanreiz sehr stark
geprägt haben was danach aber kam war
ein bisschen verbrechen an diesem
versprechen denn diese parameter
leistung muss sich wieder lohnen gelten
für viele menschen leider nicht mehr
gucken wir an was den eigentumswohnungen
in seiner stadt wo ich jetzt lebe in
münchen kostet drei zimmer 800.000 euro
in einem normalen stadtviertel ein
eigenheim 105 107 millionen unbezahlbar
ist eine stadt die von der spd regiert
würde ich weiß das wohl aber jetzt kein
beispiel das alleine steht also dieses
versprechen allein ihr müsst ihr euch
nur anstrengen dann wird das schon
das geht so leider nicht mehr und da
muss man ansetzen man muss bildung die
stärker fördern durch ganztagsschulen
die spracherwerb durch förderung eines
jeden einzelnen um diesen
aufstiegsversprechen auch wirklich klar
zu machen und unsere gesellschaft die
man sehr sehr durchlässig war eine folge
des zweiten weltkriegs auch wieder
durchlässiger zu machen vielleicht muss
man auch bei steuern einsetzen also
einkommensteuer beispielsweise aber wenn
die wohnung 800.000 euro kostet
möglicherweise sind möglicherweise in
münchen dreieinhalb bis vier prozent
grunderwerbsteuer darauf in einigen
bundesländern sechseinhalb prozent
grunderwerbsteuer das wären dann bei
800.000 rund 50.000 euro in euro
bekommen also der staat ist schon
derjenige der immer wieder ab greift und
genau diesem prinzip leistung muss sich
lohnen eigentlich entgegen steht aber
doch nicht nur die bayern
deutlich also sehen ja den steuertarif
meine stahlbau auch wir sehen wann der
spitzensteuersatz greift wir sehen auch
jetzt im wahlkampf zwei parteien sind
die massive steuererhöhungen wollen
gerade für jene die besonders viel in
einem bereich leisten beispielsweise als
unternehmer in dem sie mich jobs
schaffen mittelständler sollen ja ab
100000 beispielsweise bei den grünen
mehr steuern bezahlen aber ist doch
genau die die bei dem sich leistung
lohnt die sogar leistung für sich
erbringen und damit anderen einen job
ermöglichen also dass ich da ist der
staat derjenige für eine relative
centern zur ehrlichkeit hinzu zu sagen
dass die grundaussagen bin gewinne
reinvestiert werden dann sollte sie
besser übertragen vater hat wäre ich
dass das ist jetzt wieder witzige bei
dem statement von jens hat mich eine
sache am meisten bewegt das war jetzt
nicht die angesprochen dass mit den
kindern es wenn die arbeiten gehen ihnen
geld weggenommen wird das ist doch
unfassbar damit wird doch jungen
menschen beigebracht du kannst ruhig
arbeiten gehen aber überlegt bitte
direkt was angerechnet wird dann musst
du immer schön so arbeite ist es sehr
stark dir und deiner familie noch die
zuschüsse zeit ist doch genau das
gegenteil was wir bei bringen wollen ich
finde dieses beispiel alle politiker
erzählen besonders übrigens auch gerne
olaf scholz das natürlich man das auch
nicht weiter geben soll und auch alle
seien gut behandelt werden aber dazu
gehört auch dass wenn kinder neben der
schule arbeiten die können doch nichts
dafür ich meinen kindern was weggenommen
werden wo die eltern schon weniger haben
das ist doch gerade ein beispiel das
darf doch das hat mich total in wallung
gebracht vielleicht nur mich am tisch
aber das darf doch nicht in deutschland
passieren weil es ist doch die wahrheit
wenn jahns kinder arbeiten gehen oder
deine kinder arbeiten gehen oder die
arbeit
wird doch nichts weggenommen es ist doch
umfasst und meißen und meine these war
ja gar nicht jeder kann alles aus seinem
leben machen wenn er nur fleißig war
sondern meine these war ja wir müssen
wieder dahin kommen dass es so ist
sondern wir haben meistens
ungerechtigkeiten steuersystem dieses
beispiel bildung ist natürlich ein
schlüssel für aufstieg aber dieses
versprechen der sozialen marktwirtschaft
durch harte arbeit voran zu kommen das
müssen wir wieder erfüllen weil wir da
unsere gesellschaft wieder
leistungsfähiger ist damit die
leistungsgerechtigkeit herstellen und
dieses symbolische beispiel finde ich
einfach so
das setzt sich doch in den köpfen von
diesen jungen menschen fest wir müssten
doch eigentlich sagen wir finden das gut
wenn du durch arbeite ich auch aus
deinen sozialer status befreien stößt
anstatt sie zu bestrafen also ich möchte
kein kein staat ja irgendwie aufstiegs
bremse ist sondern flügel heber für
jungen sowie drehen weil die an die sich
auch raus arbeiten können aus ihrer
herkunft damit man nicht in ein neo
förderlandes muss landet das wir jetzt
sehr überspitzt aber das einleben wir
manchmal auch oben in den bereich ich
glaube jens orth 100 prozent recht er
könnte das eigentlich noch viel
rezitierte und was noch drastischer
vertreten diesen punkt ich beobachte mit
sorge wie in deutschland die
leistungsgesellschaft durch eine
umverteilungs gesellschaft durch eine
stadtgesellschaft
rein kollektivismus ersetzt meine schaut
euch mal die parteiprogramme die grünen
die wollen ja parlamente schon besetzen
nach geschlechterquote und nachweisen
haarfarbe oder dioptrien bei den
kurzsichtigen das hat nichts mehr mit
leistung zu tun der staat hat in
deutschland eine größe erreicht die
nichts mehr zu tun hat mit der sozialen
marktwirtschaft von ludwig erhard ich
frage mich einfach was man auch die fdp
falsch dass sie immer noch bei diesen
zehn prozent rum krebst wodurch
eigentlich deutschland der inbegriff
einer solidarischen
leistungsgesellschaft ist weil ich finde
auch die unterstellung dass die
deutschen sozusagen eine art raubtiere
gesellschaft sehen die quasi jede mit
dem ellbogen auf kosten sonst ich erlebe
deutschland dass die deutschen sind sehr
solidarisch und sie sind auch
leistungsbereit aber das problem dass
ihr habt und das ist meine kritiker die
oft an die fdp ihr seid auch zu viel
staat immer noch zu staatsgläubig ihr
wird auch in diese pöstchen rhein ihr
wird auch an die macht ihr müsstet dem
start ganz systematisch geld entziehen
ihr müsstet ludwig erhard wieder
erneuern du kommst nicht mit immer
höheren steuern zum erfolg kommen zum
wohlstand
programm ja also das tier macht von
bildern konsequent wir haben uns
innerhalb von einem jahr verdoppelt
derweil waren bei 6 prozent jetzt sind
auch mal zwölf wenn euch nicht auf aber
behoben euch da auch eine liberale
partei mit 20 prozent am liebsten
programm und noch mehr also daraus muss
ist klar aber ich glaube die
programmatik ist schon bei der fdp zu
sehen als einzige stimme in der
deutschen politiklandschaft wie stark
muss ich dann die fdp verbiegen wenn wir
möglicherweise am sonntag in den gut 45
stunden ein bundeskanzler olaf scholz
haben oder zumindest eine spd mit der
spitze olaf scholz die dann
möglicherweise vor der union liegt und
dann in eine koalition eintreten will
mit den grünen und mit den narren
christian lindner war eben bei uns bei
den jungen liberalen das streaming wg zu
gast will stream immer auftritt und er
hat natürlich wieder gesagt es gibt
keine neuen steuern mit der fdp auch bei
einer ampel habe ich jetzt auch schon
einmal wiederholt und ich habe ergänzt
er hat auch gesagt auch bei einer ampel
nicht auch bei einer ampel nicht das ist
würding von uns wir wollen keine neuen
steuern wobei
sein letzter satz ich hab ergänzt für
mich koalitionsbedingung dass das mit
den 450 euro nehmen jobs hinzuverdienst
geändert wird klares koalitions bedingt
christian hat zugestimmt das sind jetzt
die bedingungen unter anderem für eine
ampel die linien sind klar
erwirtschaften vor verteilen innovation
vor verbote freiheit statt bürokratie
das sind die grundlinien die wir aber
sie haben gerade ganz offen über die
ampel gesprochen auch dann bei dem sie
haben mich auf die ampel angesprochen
weil sie gerade sagten christian lindner
hat das auch gerade noch mal betont er
wurde gefragt ja er wurde gefragt was
sind rote linien bei einer art wie sie
dürfen das vielleicht für die zuschauer
nicht in berlin sitzen dieses auch bei
einer ampel ist natürlich das aktive
einbringen der möglichkeit einer ampel
eine ampel wurde vor einiger zeit nie
erwähnt davor wurden sie ausgeschlossen
jetzt werden bedingungen formuliert was
übersetzt bedeutet dass man sich schon
auseinandersetzt und die ampel in den
bereich des möglichen
sagte ich gesagt dass er eine ampel
mache
dann mache ich das rote linien zählen
bei jeder koalition auch eine ampel das
war das würde ja auch bei einer ampel
heißt dass eine ampel ausgeschlossen ist
im zu verschließen sie auch nicht
komplett ausschuss korrekt
okay so also wir haben jetzt heute
gelernt die ampel ist nicht
ausgeschlossen ist wird dann ist für uns
die fantasie ist das werde es mit der
fdp die fantasie wir bleiben beim
learning und geben weiter zurückfallen
will noch zwei echte könnten
die panther in sie machen
[Musik]